How do you measure the success of a pirate?
Is it by Fein is by the number of ships.
They Congo to all the amounts of treasure.
They pillaged surely Henry every deserves to be in contention for the title of
most successful pirates in history,
because he was responsible for the single most profitable pirate rate in
history.
Just one school that netted every and his crew around $600,000 in
golden jewels,
the plums was so large that it resulted in what many considered to be the first
global mansions in history as Henry,
every became the most wanted man on the planet.
Well then every accomplished something almost unheard of in his line of work,
something that almost no other famous pirate managed to do,
he got away with it back then pirates were fated to meet their end either at the
bottom of Davy Jones, his locker, or at the end of her rope at the gallows.
But Henry every got his big score,
took his share of the treasure and disappeared into the midst of time.
Never to be heard from again, this alone truly made him worthy of the sobriquet.
The King of pirates.
[Inaudible].
This is the case with other pirates.
We find ourselves knocking a lot of credible sources on the early life of Henry.
Every, sometimes he spelled his name, Avery burst.
He also went by a few other monikers throughout his career,
such as Benjamin Bridgeman, long Ben and John Avery,
which is believed to have been the name of his father.
He was born most likely in 1653 or 1659,
depending on the source near the English port city of Plymouth in the County of
Devon, his parents were probably John and Anne every and some historians have
speculated that they may have been connected to the prominent every family which
owned a lot of land in Devin and even had a branch that became baronets Henry
every took to the sea from a young age,
serving on both merchants and Royal Navy ships. According to one account,
every was part of the English fleet, the bombarded outages, and 1671.
He served as the captain of a log would freighter in the Bay of campy in the
Gulf of Mexico, and also traveled to the Caribbean for a while,
where he operated as a buck. And yet,
unfortunately all of these stories come from a contemporary book called the life
and adventures of captain John Avery published in 1709.
It was written by Adrian van brogues pseudonym of a man who claimed he was a
captive of every during his pirating days. Unfortunately,
there is absolutely nothing to corroborate his tails and the book has been
dismissed as almost certainly a work of fiction with the occasional truth
included.
We get a better understanding of every career off to the breakouts of the nine
years' war in 1688.
It was four between France on the one side and pretty much all the other
European powers. On the other side,
who formed a coalition known as the grand Alliance. We first hear of every,
when he was in his early thirties, serving as a midshipman,
a the 64 gun ship of the line,
HMS report records also seem to indicate that he already had a family at this
point and D had sent them most of his wages in 1689.
The HMS report played an important in capturing a French convoy off the coast of
the port city of breasts, following the success. Most officers board,
the warships received promotions, including every who became a masters meet,
which is a title that doesn't exist anymore.
It is probable that the captain of the ships,
a Francis Wheeler took every with him the following year,
when he was put in charge of a launch,
it deadly at 90 gun ship called the HMS Abel, Mel, if this is true,
then it's also likely that every participated in the battle of beachy head on
July, the 10th, 60 90, which ended up being a crushing defeat, the English,
it seems that he was discharged from the Royal Navy the following month
afterwards, it appears that Henry Everi joins the slave trade for a few years.
Although this part of his life is poorly documented.
So we don't know what ships he served the board and what ranks. You had
1693 Henry every joined a new venture called Spanish expedition shipping at the
time the West Indies and the Caribbean sea were split between the Spanish and
the French who were still at war with each other. Spain was England's allies.
So a group of wealthy London, merchants forms this expedition,
which consisted of three frigates and a pink, the flagship being the Charles,
the second's named off to the King of Spain.
The mission was to travel to the Spanish West Indies to trade salvage,
supply the Spanish with guns. And most importantly,
it plums are all the friendships that they met along the way.
Basically they were English privateers under a commissioned by the Spanish King,
based on his record and experience Henry every was made first made of the
Charles the second's. This seems like a pretty sweet gig at first,
but it quickly went South as one bad thing happens after another first,
the original captain of the Charles the second died while the ship was still in
port. When the fleet finally left England,
it headed for the Spanish city of Karuna. However,
thanks to delays and bad weather, the trip,
which was supposed to take two weeks and lasted five months.
When they finally found themselves in Spain,
they have to sit and pause for a few more months because the necessary paperwork
and not yet arrived during all this time,
just waiting around the men weren't getting paid and they were becoming
desperate upon joining the expedition. They had been given one months,
pay in advance and promised a guaranteed salary to be paid every six months.
Once the ships were finally getting ready to leave for the West Indies,
the crew demanded the six months wages before heading out their request was
denied. And unsurprisingly, this endeavor only had one possible outcome.
And that of course is mutinied according to reports from sailors who stayed
behind Henry. Every was one of the driving forces behind the mutiny,
going from ship to ship and talking to all of the men to persuade them,
to join us site on may the seventh, 1694,
he and dozens of sailors storms the Charles the second and took the rest of its
crew by surprise,
before the other ships realized what was happening into time to react,
he took the flagship into open water. Once they were far enough from Spain,
the former captain and all of the men who did not want to join were placed in a
boot and allowed to go to shore.
The only one who was forced to stay was the ship surgeon,
as his services would be valuable to forgo Henry.
Every was named the new and he rechristened the ship of the fancy.
[Inaudible].
Now there's Henry ever. He was a pirate and D at a ship and D at a crew.
He needed one more thing. And that was a destination. Where should they head to,
to engage in radical ways? Well, back then there was a popular sailing routes,
particularly used by English core says w simply there's a pirate around which
targeted the many merchant ships that traveled between North America or Western
Europe and Southern Asia.
It started from the Atlantic ocean that rounded the tip of Africa,
POS the Cape of good height with a stop on Madagascar.
Back then this Island was a safe Haven for pirates and a great place where
resupply ends before ship maintenance from that they would set various
destinations, which allow them to prowl the Indian ocean, looking for Tongans.
In fact,
every was one of the pirates who popularized this route since it was here,
he took the biggest prize of his life,
which we'll talk about a bit later for now.
We see him and his crew sailing off the coast of Africa,
whether or not every committed,
any acts of piracy during this trip is yet another onset. And the points,
according to a general history of pirates written in 1724,
by the mysterious captain, Charles Johnson,
Henry every did not take any praises into reaching that a gasket that he
encountered two pirates snoops that quickly ran a grounds when they saw him as
that crew scrambled to hide in the woods,
believing that the fridge was still sailing under the British crown and was that
to take them down every sense on arms messengers,
to talk to the pirates and even volunteered to join them himself in order to
convince them that his ship was no longer flying the British flag.
Eventually once they were assured that he was telling the truth,
the other privates gleefully joined every is now with the frigate on their side,
they could take down much more valuable prizes as forever.
He had only been a pirate captain for a few weeks,
but was already building up a nice fleet for himself. Again,
all of this is according to Johnson.
And as we already discussed in our biographics video out black bids,
you might want to check that one out. If you miss.
This is identity is such a big question, Mark,
that we can't even say with certainty, that he was a real person,
pretty much everything he wrote comes under scrutiny.
But unfortunately it is also one of the main sources for figures from the golden
age of piracy. Other sources say that every was far more active as a pirate,
right from the stops allegedly his first prize was in fact,
a triple three English merchant ships that he captured a mayor.
One of the islands that formed the Cape Verde archipelago near the Northwest
coast of Africa. He continued onto Madagascar,
but took several more prizes on his way,
including two Dutch privateers and a French pirate ship,
which yielded dozens of men who were willing to join his crew
In 1695, Henry every set his sights on a very ambitious targets,
perhaps the most ambitious,
but also the most rewarding targets sailing the Indian ocean,
the grands Moogle fleet during the 17th century.
Most of the Indian subcontinent meaning most of India itself,
plus parts of Pakistan, Afghanistan, and Bangladesh.
What parts of the Moogle empire and every time this land was ruled by emperor
Aurangzeb every year, the empire formed a fleet to escort Muslim worshipers,
who went on the pilgrimage to Mecca cool. The Hodge in 1695,
that convoy consisted of 25 ships, but they were not just carrying pilgrims.
They also included merchant ships that were filled to the brim with gold and
other treasures among them.
The biggest prize of the flotilla was the Gange ease Salwa meaning exceeding
treasure. That's also Anglicised as the gun's way.
It was the time of Indian trading ship go to ganja Dow.
And in September it left the port of mocca and was returning to Surat in India.
How exactly every new of the dates, when the fleet left port,
we're not sure maybe he got a tip or maybe it was widely available information
since it was an annual pilgrimage, either way.
He realized that even just one of the merchant ships,
which make for the biggest prize of his life, but he couldn't do it alone.
Not only were the merchant vessels armed,
they also had washer past scored since they were traveling in dangerous waters,
no every needed help. And he got it from five other pirate captains.
You all wanted in on the action.
They would tell them as to you who sailed aboard the Amity Thomas wake,
who captain the Susanna Joseph Pharaoh on the Portsmouth adventure.
Richard wants on the dolphin and Willy amaze about the pole. Realistically,
apart from every only Thomas two was already a notable pirate in his own, right?
The others ones that have been challenged of their flu tiller is the most
experienced captain, but every eventually won out,
mainly because he had the biggest and most powerful ship in August, 1695,
the pirates met at the Bab El Mendez straits. This connects the red seeds,
the Gulf of Aden and waited for the grands Moodle fleet to pass through.
It is actually unclear if every ends,
the other captains have met each other previously and agreed to convene here,
or if they all simply showed up at the same time with the same intentions and
decided that six ships were better than one, either way in September,
the Bruegel convoy pass through these waters and the pirate scape chase.
When the Moogle shifts saw the pirates, they began dispersing the Ganges wide.
There's the biggest ship in the fleet immediately fell behind.
Desert did its act score to the smaller part hammer Hamot even.
So it became clear quite soon,
but some of the pirate ships were ill fitted to this ambitious rate.
The dolphin proved almost useless immediately as it was too slow to keep up with
the rest of the ships.
Eventually most of them had abandoned ship and joined every on the fancy
meanwhile, Thomas to you and the Amity engaged in a fight through the fascia and
Mohammad's, which had disastrous consequences for the pirates too,
was killed by Canon shops that allegedly a giant hole through his stomach,
horrified the rest of his men immediately surrendered and gave up the chase.
Lastly,
the Susanna also struggled to maintain the speed of the other vessels and was
only present at certain points of the raid, which lasted over a week.
The first ship that ever eons the rest managed to catch up to it was the fatter
Mohamad still damaged from its engagements, with the Amity,
the mogul ship surrendered its alone contained enough plunder to make the rate
of success.
Every however was determined to get his hands on the Ganges to why a few days
later on September the seventh, he managed to catch up to the trading ship.
At that point only the fancy,
the Portsmith adventure and the bowl were still combat worthy.
On the other side of the Mongol vessel was armed with dozens of canons and 400
rifleman. The odds appeared to be in the favor of the mogul ship,
but every had no intention of backing down.
Now the same cannot be said for Joseph far, a board,
the Portsmouth adventure who decided not to engage fortunately forever.
He also had luck on his side during the fight.
One of his first cannon volleys destroyed the Ganges wise main mass leaving the
vessel slow and vulnerable. More importantly though, one of the Mughal ships,
cannons, malfunctioned and exploded killing its gunners,
setting the deck on fire and causing a lot of panic and confusion.
The pirates seized the opportunity to open fire from all sides afterward,
successfully boarding the Ganges swine overpowering the crew from an Indian
perspective, contemporary historian,
caffeine con blamed the defeat on the captain of the Ganges to why Muhammad
Abraham, besides his incompetency also acted cowardly at one point,
allegedly running below decks on these slave girls and telling them to fight for
him.
Colin also reported that what followed was far more gruesome than the flight
itself, as the pirates, subjected the people, the board,
the Mughal ship days of torture, rape,
and murder with many of them committing suicide by jumping overboard to escape
the horrifying act off two days of barbarity,
the pirates were ready to leave with their spoils.
The exact value of dilute is difficult to estimate,
but it was somewhere between 325,000 pounds and 600,000 pounds.
Plus another 50,000 pounds from the fascia and Muhammad.
This would mean over a hundred million dollars in modern currency. But again,
that's just a rough estimate.
The point is that one share represented more money than any sailor made in a
lifetime and more than enough for them to retire.
But we do arrive now at another contentious point,
sharing the spoils who got what there were no participation trophies in
piracy.
Although six chips started out only the two that actually fought the gangee.
So why we're entitled to any of its riches.
We have one accounts of what happened again, courtesy of Charles Johnson.
He said that every betrayed the other pirate ship and sailed away with the
entire loot after convincing them that the safest place to store it was the
cargo hold of the fancy once that was done.
He and his crew simply deposited onto the cover of night. According to sources,
there was a heated argument between the crews of the fantasy and the pole after
the former accused the latter of trying to cheat them by clipping coins,
as punishments, every confiscated, the treasure wrote to the bowl.
And instead only provided them with a modest sum to cover supplies and repairs.
Once news.
Want it to spread about the attack on the Ganges,
why to say that it caused a commotion would be the understatement of the
century.
And for orange Zeb flew into a rage once he learned about his treasure being
stolen, but also about the farmer of the pilgrims returning from Mecca,
he immediately placed the English and Surratt under arrest and closed down
factories,
which belonged to the East India company with the intention of completely
severing trade ties with England.
Eventually there a point in history when the East India company became the
largest private company in the war Wells and at a private army,
much larger than that Britain,
which used to rule over India for a century that point, however,
we're still 60 years away.
So for now they were at the mercy of the Mughal emperor.
They promised to cover all the financial losses caused by the rate.
And they placed a 500 pound bounty on everybody's head,
which was later double to a thousand pounds, which was unheard of at the time.
It also came with a free pardon for any pirate you turned him in to,
but it's simply Henry ever. He became the most wanted man on the planet.
The pirates might've successfully planted the treasure,
but getting away with it would be a whole new challenge entirely first off,
they needed to decide where they would sail. Next.
Initially they traveled to a French islands near Madagascar named Bobo,
and which was a safe Haven for pirates.
That is where they divvied up their loot and plans. Then next step,
some of the men stayed on Bolden.
Others left the crew and secured passage on different ships on their own.
As for Henry every and the rest of the pirates, the board, the fancy,
they decided that The Bahamas would be the safest place for them in March, 1696,
the fantasy arrived in new Providence.
The islands that contains the Bahama and capita lived in a cell that every
adopted the name,
Henry Bridgman and convinced the governors and Nicholas trots that they were
unlicensed, slavers hiding from the East India company,
accompanied by a generous bribe.
The story was enough to secure the pirates safe Haven in the South.
It probably didn't hurt that every ship was the most powerful vessel for
hundreds of miles.
So the governor had the choice to be the making a friend or an enemy, even.
So when you're the target of the largest manhunt in the world,
your cover will not last forever,
especially when your wealth mostly consists of diamonds and foreign gold coins.
Whenever his true identity was discovered, trot had no other choice,
but to issue an arrest warrant for him to avoid making himself complicit in this
escape, even. So the governor,
clearly it was not a friend of the East India company or the British government,
as he tipped off, every the ships were on the way to arrest him.
The captain and most of his crew had time to escape with only a few men staying
behind and getting captured. It seemed inevitable that everywhere Henry,
every went to someone would discover his true identity.
And yet he seemingly did the impossible Henry, every vanished,
nobody knows what ultimately happened to him, his crew, his ship,
or his treasure. Everything from this point on is pure hearsay and rudeness.
Allegedly, they tried going to Jamaica,
but the same thing happens as in the South from that the crew split into groups,
some stayed behind in the Caribbean,
most traveled to North America and the last group, which included every himself,
returns to England under assumed names.
The most complete account is given by Charles Johnson. Again,
he said that Henry ever refis traveled to Boston intending to settle in the new
world, but changed his mind. And later sail to Ireland from them.
He needed a way of selling his ill-gotten gains without being discovered.
He made an arrangement with some merchants in Bristol,
but they ripped him off and stole most of his share of the treasure.
Every couldn't do anything against them as they threatened to expose his true
identity. So he retaught almost penniless to a town in Devin called Bedford.
This version of the story is so much more detailed than all the other accounts
that unless Charles Johnson personally met Henry every some point it is almost
certainly a complete fabrication.
The reality is that we'll probably never truly know what the ultimate fate was
of the King of the pirates. So I really hope you found that video. Interesting.
If you did, please do hit that thumbs up button below.
Don't forget to subscribe and thank you for watching.